allora certo che dopo una testimonianza
di questo tipo il mio ruolo è molto che
riduttivo perché veramente ha detto
delle parole straordinarie dette da un
uomo che è nato in un'isola io sono nato
in un isola quindi condivido in pieno il
pensiero dell'imprenditore uomo
difficoltà di diciamo impegnarsi che
nella propria terra o vi vorrei dare
questa sera tante ricette vi vorrei fare
sentire i profumi perché il coraggio del
cuoco passa anche attraverso i fuochi la
cucina gli ingredienti la territorialità
del prodotto il rispetto a immenso che
ci deve essere per il contadino perché
il contadino la figura cardine della
nostra attività noi siamo solamente
degli esecutori
quindi il coraggio del contadino che
mette ogni giorno nel coltivare il pezzo
di terra in seminare raccogliere è
proteggere qualcosa di importante che
poi va a finire praticamente a noi o
alle donne di casa per trasformarla in
cibo e quindi adesso praticamente in
queste ore di attesa ho preso un po di
appunti e con l'uso della tecnologia che
non sono molto bravo praticamente ho
scritto alcuni spunti da sviluppare il
cuoco il coraggio di non lamentarsi il
coraggio di essere consapevoli e donarsi
agli altri
questo vale per tutti i lavori quando
una persona decide di fare qualcosa per
gli altri deve essere totalmente a
disposizione della comunità e delle
persone che decidono di avere un
approccio col nostro mestiere
quindi massimo rispetto e il coraggio
dei lavoratori che stanno praticamente
18 ore al giorno
no a pensare di fare qualcosa di buono
il coraggio di affrontare i cambiamenti
generazionali e se il caso affrontati
con umiltà
adesso noi non mangiamo più come 50 anni
fa perché lo stress è maggiore il clima
è differente il prodotto cresce in
maniera totalmente differente appunto da
tantissimi anni fa
i nostri nonni ci hanno insegnato a
nutrirci con pochissimi elementi con la
cucina povera sostanziosa fatta di
dignità
oggi il cuoco deve essere ambasciatore
di quello che noi dobbiamo assolutamente
incamerare dentro il nostro corpo è il
nostro fisico perché purtroppo è
abituata a digerire in un'altra maniera
di tantissimi anni fa quindi rispetto
per l'ingrediente e territorialità del
prodotto che è una cosa che ripeterò
sempre
il coraggio di rimettersi in discussione
a prescindere dal dio danaro rischiare e
svuotarsi da tutto non bisogna
assolutamente lavorare per quanto mi
riguarda e lo dico perché somma che mi
ascolta gente che in questo momento mi
conosce per il dio danaro cioè chi
insegue i soldi in maniera assoluta in
qualsiasi campo è destinato a fallire
qualsiasi progetto i soldi arrivano
quando l'umiltà è talmente tanta da non
fare più caso se la gente viene da te
per pagarti perché non bisogna
assolutamente essere comprati o
acquistati da nessuno
cioè quelle una chiarezza di pensiero di
cui io faccio praticamente che il verbo
assoluto il coraggio di non sentirsi
assoluti ma prendere parte alla vita e
rispettare la gente in difesa che
subisce ingiustizie da parte di
ciarlatani che si credono forti e
coraggiosi qualsiasi mestiere qualsiasi
settore
ci sono tante persone che non capiscono
assolutamente nulla e purtroppo
sfruttano a volte la
a me delle persone quindi se io faccio
il ristoratore devo essere assolutamente
sicuro che l'ingrediente che compro e
ottimo a discapito anche delle nostre
tasche personali per far sì che la gente
debba assolutamente conservare un buon
ricordo col cibo che ingoia perché il
rapporto tra il cuoco è il commensale e
intimissimo io penso una ricetta la
cucina è la do a chi la mangia e quella
persona porterà per ore e ore un ricordo
dentro di sé quindi che deve essere
assolutamente straordinario è positivo
soprattutto il coraggio di esserci e non
apparire non tutti hanno la possibilità
di guardare dovremmo anche farci sentire
attraverso i suoni della nostra anima
a volte il rapporto fra le persone
totalmente distaccato guarda che c'è
questa cosa di abbracciarci dire ciao
che fai come stai
ma fondamentalmente forse non ce ne
frega assolutamente niente
e oggi c'è tanta gente che ha bisogno di
tutto appunto per questo motivo perché
noi siamo concentrati troppo che col
nostro io e ci guardiamo poco attorno in
questo caso il cuoco deve essere quella
persona almeno io che almeno venti volte
l'anno deve dare il mio operato alla
gente che ha bisogno a prescindere da
tutto dobbiamo essere un po i pellegrini
del cibo dobbiamo che regalare è una
esperienza è una gioia il coraggio e
quello delle madri di un campo profughi
in sudan incontrate alla settimana
scorsa ho avuto questa esperienza che ho
definito l'esperienza della vita e non
vi racconto quello che ho fatto che nei
10 53 anni che ho fatto tantissime cose
e lì ti rendi conto qual è il coraggio
di una madre per nutrire i figli
in un campo profughi senza acqua senza
cibo senza luce e senza scarichi vivendo
in case di fango e li tu ti rendi conto
come un la donna è l'emblema assoluta
del coraggio cioè perché la donna
praticamente nutre cioè a discapito
delle difficoltà e di tutto una creatura
che nasce dentro di lei attraverso anche
noi
e ovvio però riesce praticamente a
isolare il figlio da tutte le difficoltà
che ci sono purtroppo in questo mondo
grazie